Today, I want to a quick look at how to
use a web server with Cloud Shell
First, activate your Cloud Shell. Now I'm going to
make a simple web server in Node.js
Here, I've pasted my code in. You can see it's a
simple hello world app that's listening
on port 3000. I'm gonna change that to
port 8080 so it works better with Cloud Shell
and now I'm gonna start the node
server just like you would on your local
machine. At this point we can start the
web preview. You can choose a different
port, but I'm just going to choose port
8080. A new tab gets opened up
automatically and we can see our code
running. To show you it runs in
real-time, I'm gonna change the code to
say "Hello World, I'm using Cloud Shell". If
I rerun my server and refresh the page I
can see the new code up and running